hey you feeling good is this farewell no
am I not gonna have somebody to stand
next to me next year and make me feel
incredibly short no somebody said to me
you know either Dan's really tall or
you're really short I said both yeah
there was a report yesterday on Sporting
News and I didn't know anything about it
because I'm doing the pre thank God I
didn't know anything about the pregame
you know this during pregame because it
said are you reuniting with Keith
Oberman it's sports then I go what year
is this like no I'm not
and you know so all of a sudden it
became a story and then no my son I'm at
dinner last night after the Super Bowl
so I've been working for 12 hours tired
and he goes uh you know about the ESPN
thing down I go what he goes know about
you going back seriously you don't know
I go just tell me what what are you
talking about so he tells me that next
thing I know I'm texting my agent going
uh can you inform me what the hell's
going on there he said no ESPN is gonna
clarify this that they they made a
mistake and how they worded this because
I was trying to get sports jeopardy on
there my broadcasting school ESPN to be
affiliated with that so no I'm not going
back to the six o'clock well I'm
relieved in continue to do football
nights America continued when I feel
incredibly small blood pools want to
make sure it's semantics you're not
going back to six o'clock SportsCenter
there's multiple sports centers
throughout the day then just clarify I'm
not going back to do sports in what
about Sunday NFL countdown that was in
the article you could could you do that
and football night in America it's not
that far of a drive wait that was you
know oh yeah oh my god yeah I didn't
read it
ratings are down for Sunday no no no
that's three hours of work there what
are your sources telling you about this
nothing yet I I'm too worried about
trying to figure out what's going on
with all these Patriots or to supposedly
jump in ship or not alright we'll get to
that in a moment
by the way I did meet with John skipper
and we talked about the other things not
doing NFL countdown I don't want to do
that it's too much work but with you
know they have like 25 people on the
show so you'd only be on like ten
minutes right if I could do the final
hour of NFL countdown every one thing
alright so let's start with Malcolm
Butler do we know anything more about
why he was benched last night no
we don't and I don't know that we ever
will because it's not in his interest to
come out and say whatever it was he had
to have done something dan that that
upset Bill Belichick close in time to
the start of the game because he found
out not long before kickoff that he
wasn't playing and Eric Rowe his
replacement found out that he would be
playing that's not ideal for a Super
Bowl like hey Eric oh by the way yeah
you're actually gonna be in the starting
lineup so there has to be a story here
something had to have happened yesterday
or Saturday night that prompted Bill
Belichick to say I'm gonna send a
message to the team even if it
undermines our ability to win the game
and you know I know Tom Curren had a
strong opinion about a costume the game
and maybe it did because at some point
you have to say what we're doing isn't
working malcom go out there and try to
do better than what we can't stop them
so surely Malcolm Butler could have at
least done as poorly as what everyone
else was doing yeah I'm trying to figure
that out because he was available we had
heard that he had the flu or he was
under the weather
he played special teams yeah but not a
lot I don't think did he but that
obviously you know we're watching and
Tony Dungy and Rodney Harrison and John
Harbaugh and we're going where's Butler
and we couldn't get any answers from
anybody even listening to Cris
Collinsworth and Al Michaels you
couldn't get any information there and
even afterwards felt like the Patriots
even you know Matt Patricia the
defensive coordinators like the targets
he's learned from the best yes yeah all
right we also heard that maybe josh
mcdaniels wasn't going to Indianapolis
there's something weird going on there
and I think he still may go but being in
the Super Bowl City for the whole week
you see a bunch of different people you
talk to a bunch of different people and
you start to pick up some weird vibes
and it was a week ago Tuesday that I
started to get a sense that maybe this
McDaniels thing isn't as done of a deal
is and you know they'll tell you all the
time it's not a done deal until it's
really a done deal so he could back out
if he wanted to I mean nothing's
official yet
and I started to poke around like well
where does this really stand and I was
told at one point that Matt Patricia the
defensive coordinator has essentially
made it clear that he's leaving to coach
the Lions but josh mcdaniels hasn't told
the Patriots he's leaving so well what
would it take for him to stay and I
think that one theory is he's angling
for a commitment that he would replace
Bill Belichick but I don't think the
Patriots gonna give him that because
things can change and nobody knows how
long Belichick is gonna coach Robert
Kraft told me back in March he wants
the coach into his 80s so who knows what
kind of a commitment they'd be making
five years seven-year tenure so I I
don't I don't know where this all goes
but there is a weird vibe and I think
there's a combination Dan of maybe the
cults not being a hundred percent
comfortable with McDaniels because they
had to sell or say on it but it's more
importantly McDaniels not being honored
percent comfortable with the cults and
not being comfortable with working for
Jim are saying not ready to make that
leap because he's already had a failed
head coaching job when you go for the
second one you better get it right but
also you have to you know factor in
Belichick and how long he wants to do
this now I didn't know if there was a
scenario where if the Patriots had one
last night that Bill Belichick rides off
into the sunset what's he gonna do
that's a thing it's his lifestyle he's
built this infrastructure where
everything is set it's his it's it's
just his routine what would Bill
Belichick do if he wasn't coaching could
be like a defensive line coach at
navier's lacrosse and he'd probably
daughter coaches lacrosse I just I can't
imagine him finding the fulfillment and
it's almost like with Nick Saban you
climb to the top of the mountain and
then you go back to the bottom and you
climb the same mountain again and you go
back to the bottom but once you climb it
that many times that you set the bar so
far out there that no one's ever gonna
come close to it I think that's what
drives these guys the Gronk retirement
talk I know it's in the moment but he
was healthy this year he was using Tom
Brady's health guru and stopped drinking
during the season at least cut down on
his rise retiring so he can drink what
do you make of those comments well you
know that was another one where there's
a weird vibe throughout the week and I
think it's a combination of the hit that
he took from Barry Church 15 days ago in
the AFC Championship game I don't think
he's ever been hit like that before in
the head I think he struggled to pass
the concussion protocol to get clearance
to play I believe that people close to
him family members are pushing him at
least one maybe more pushing him to step
aside he's never spent a dollar of his
football money he lives off of his
marketing money and the question becomes
eight million dollars next year to stay
with the Patriots how much money can he
make just being wrong I mean there's an
itch out there you don't want to stray
from a very far I've seen him act you
don't want to do that I've seen him do
the comedy thing Fritzie you got him
beat by about a
time's right but there's a there's a
bronc being drunk
we're just be gone when I go to barstool
and just be Gronk do do the crews do one
a month just be Gronk and be that guy
and make five million a year and not get
hit in the head and not have to have
five arm surgeries and a knee surgery
and ankle surgery and back surgeries and
and be able to have a long and fruitful
life I think that that's on the table
and I think if they 2-1 he'd have been
out I don't know if you guys played the
sound but when they asked him about it
after the game any truth to the rumor of
you retiring listen god here's Rob
Gronkowski this is the question an
answer after the game as retirement
already crossed your mind you've
actually put thought into it
we just lost I mean I just wanna
just sit back relax in those couple
weeks and I really really got nothing to
say about that right now
you heard that but I mean I'm definitely
going to look at my future
what sit down the next couple weeks
Superman all right so he didn't want to
talk about it but he didn't exactly
dispel that What did he say first I
don't know you how you heard about that
yeah it was we did the postgame share
last night on NBCSN and Chris Sam said
what's that I
how'd you hear about there's nothing to
hear about it there's nothing to it I
think if they'd won he's gone and now
that they lost he needs to figure out
what he's gonna do next cuz that's the
perfect scenario walk away with a
Lombardi Trophy had a great performance
this year he made the extra five point
five million dollars in incentives he
came out of it fairly healthy I do think
the concussion is an issue and and you
walk away and now the question becomes
is he's still gonna walk away but I
think it's real and if you're thinking
about it and talking about it you do
that I don't know how you heard about
that I think it's real yeah athletes
will tell you when you start thinking or
talking about retirement you might as
well retire we're talking to Mike Florio
from pro football talk
let can you stay I want to talk to you
about looking at drama in the off season
here what are you finding out you know
with the draft coming up since it's our
last time together I may as well stay as
long as you want me yeah well once I get
that yes parking spot back I just got to
figure out if I can bring it down that's
there to ESPN to work on the six o'clock
SportsCenter with me Fritzi I'll bring
you back you can book some guests the
other guys you're on your own maybe you
go next door Rich Eisen can add a couple
of eyes and nets that'd be nice
all right 15 just just joking sorry
sorry about that just joking
all right a little truth and every bit
of kidding 16 after the hour will come
back with Mike Florio after this and the
Dan Patrick show I'm just talking like
Florrie on the Dan ads we're doing our
rundown meaning for the Super Bowl we
get done I go outside I get some food
outside I see Chris Sims Chris Sims goes
hey man I'm getting killed I'm getting
killed by you know people on the on
Twitter you know because I said Blake
bortles is the 70th best passer I go but
you did say that over again yes yeah he
goes yeah but I said it on your show I
said yeah you said it on my show you
also said I think he should throw left
handed not right somehow I'm the blame
because he came on and said something
stupid he was not put on earth to throw
the football that he he says at all
about Blake bortles and and like when he
has a good game he moves him from 70 to
67 66 and then it's back to 70 again and
he's 70 is where he's locked in Mike
Florio staying with us from Pro Football
Talk
what is Blake bortles future in
Jacksonville well there was a report
last week that the Jaguars are gonna
keep him it's 19 million dollars under
the fifth-year option for 2018 and I
feel like you have to just be willing to
rip the name off the back of the jersey
and say what else could we do for the
same money or less or a little bit more
right if case keenum ends up being
available I'd take Case Keenum over
Blake bortles I thought one strategy
would be to cut him before the 19
million becomes fully guaranteed on
March 14 and just sit back and see what
happens because who else is gonna rush
to give Blake bortles huge money so
maybe you can get him for less than that
and and I think they've just kind of
been dismayed because they've had
success with him so now what do we do we
have to keep him but he's not the answer
and I feel like they're just one
quarterback very good quarterback away
from being the team that's hoisting the
next Lombardi what about Nick Foles his
future you know the the sense coming
from the Eagles before they won the
Super Bowl was they have to keep him
because they need a great backup to
Carson Wentz because of Carson Wentz his
playing style he's not going to change
it he's had the torn ACL he's had other
injuries he plays with that physicality
that is conducive to getting hurt
so you have to have foals air they got
them in a contract I think for seven
million for next year that's a great
deal yeah but now what happens if
somebody calls you up and says hey Super
Bowl MVP will offer you a first-round
draft pick for Nick Foles do you take it
and move on they got the first-round
pick and a fourth round pick I think for
Sam Bradford and I think maybe they just
hold onto foals
the same way they had foals and or
Bradford and Wentz a couple of years ago
and just wait and see and and maybe they
can flip that into an asset but they
better feel good about whoever the
backup is to Carson Wentz cuz you never
know when that guy's gonna have to play
and play well explain to me what's going
on with Kirk Cousins right now well wait
a min hold on Kirk Kirk not Curt look
here's the reality Washington has a deal
in place to get Alex Smith and
Washington if they want to be cute they
can franchise tag Kirk Cousins again and
then try to trade him too complicated
though and it's thirty four and a half
million dollars to
tag him again why wouldn't cousins just
accept it right away and say hey I'll
take thirty four and a half million if
you want to play me play me if you don't
don't if you want to have me and Alec
Smith fine I'm getting thirty four and a
half a million dollars on top of the
forty four million I've got in the last
two years I think that and one source
characterized it to me yesterday as
Washington playing a pettiness game but
you could trade him to Cleveland though
what despite him yeah but here's the
thing he has to sign the franchise
tender and then Cleveland has to take
that contract well they're gonna take a
one-year deal for thirty four million
and then next year it would be another
forty four percent raise on top of it
even if you can tag them a fourth time
open question under the labor deal
whether you've even used the tag a
fourth time so what are you getting in
return for Kirk Cousins and I think of
all players on the team Dan the
quarterback has to be all in you can't
trade for Kirk Cousins if he doesn't
want to be there and when the Patriots
did it with Matt Cassel he was on board
with the process he worked with the
Patriots to let them trade him if
Cousins isn't isn't going to cooperate
it becomes impossible and I think
Washington is just trying to make him
sweat a little bit
maybe maybe come up with some sort of a
scheme to keep him from hitting the open
market but I don't think they'll be able
to pull it off and they're playing with
fire they tagged him he signs it they're
stuck for thirty four and a half million
what are you hearing at the top of the
draft it's all over the place at this
point I saw Mel Kiper had Josh Allen at
number one there's been some buzz about
the Browns falling in love with Baker
Mayfield what a shock that Jimmy has him
the owner of the Browns would fall in
love with the next Johnny Manziel
potential at least from a playing
standpoint because he was all over
Manziel four years ago and they need
that franchise quarterback and I what
and and people say this in jest but when
you have pick one in four and given your
history with quarterbacks why not take a
quarterback with each pick right it's a
coin flip and the Browns would be the
only team that would come up tails
both times but but they need that
franchise quarterback on and and you
know can they attract to Kirk Cousins
probably not he wants to win so I think
they have to hope that they can finally
get a guy that they can groom to become
a great quarterback and and hope that
they can make him into their group that
great quarterback and that they don't
pass on the next Carson Wentz or deshaun
Watson
Panthers are up for sale I don't know
the the likelihood of they would move
out of Charlotte but I was told
something interesting yesterday
and I trust the source because he's with
an owner the price tag for the Panthers
three billion dollars it could get to
three billion dollars I was told look
we're all worth whatever someone will
pay us and if you have enough suitors at
the table that are willing to bid bid it
up then yeah remember how shocked we
were when Steve Ballmer paid two billion
for the Clippers it's like this is the
LA B team in the NBA and it's worth 2
billion but if there's somebody's gonna
put that money together they see the
value they see the long-term growth of
the the of the franchise I can see it
happened if you have enough people who
want it and they have enough money that
they can justify doing it it wouldn't
surprise me but the likelihood that that
team could be outside of Charlotte well
what we've seen nearly 10% of the league
relocate or get permission to relocate
in the last two years between the
Chargers the Rams and the Raiders and
and I think when it gets to the point of
building or significantly renovating a
new stadium if you don't have the local
will to provide the public money if the
owners gonna pay for it himself okay
fine I'll I'll pay for the stadium in a
bigger market where I'm going to be able
to use the stadium more profitably on
the other 355 days when we're not
playing football and that's why Stan
Kroenke said no to st. Louis st. Louis
was gonna give him a large chunk of
money for a new stadium but I bought my
own Stadium in LA I'll build it I'll
have 20 NFL games every year I'll have
events the rest of the year and I'll
make all my money back and then some and
I I think just economics is gonna become
a bigger and bigger part of it
especially if the public money isn't
there like it used to be what's the big
offseason issue or topic that we should
keep an eye on that's okay right and I
said this on Friday I wasn't joking when
I said this town Michael is that maybe
the Super Bowl ends and it's a
controversial play it almost did that
way with Zach Ertz yeah white to me I
don't care what happens once you land
not in the end right they need you to
things out or out of bounds right I just
don't care
treat the boundaries and the end zones
differently so if you are going to the
ground but you get the ball across the
Lance Moore play the two pointer from
Super Bowl 44 they used to call it the
second act rule that if you got it
across it didn't matter if you lost
possession when you
the ground and they need to do that and
zones different feel to play different
rule if you are going to the ground but
the main thing they need to do there's
three elements to the rule one you get
two hands on the ball two you get two
feet or another body part on the ground
three you have the ball long enough to
clearly become a runner one into subject
to replay review its objective it's
clear if they got the two feet down or
they didn't for example but element
three subjective right so make it not
subject to replay review that last part
that drives us crazy no did they have
the ball long enough to clearly become a
runner if the official on the field
thought so we're not gonna look at it
just like pass interference it's a
judgment call why break it down frame by
frame and try to come to that conclusion
I think if they would combine those two
things then I think they'd have it fixed
just the finish means they'll never do
it yeah but now I think they're gonna go
back to square one here's the problem I
go back to square one and reconstruct
the rule you're gonna have all sorts of
crazy unintended consequences on the
back end when the when the Commissioner
want like he's not quite sure what it is
or how do you change it you can't say
we're gonna look at you know maybe
making changes without telling me like
what are you looking at in those changes
I mean we love replay I think that we've
broken it down though it's frame by
frame and in that frame by frame it does
a disservice to the game because I can
see movement right almost in every catch
but you know this the Corey Clement
catch last night down on that drive
where the Eagles really answered and
when it felt like the Patriots are ready
to take over that that frame-by-frame
balls moving around did you have two
feet down after you finally had control
the ball that's the kind of play that
during the regular season however on the
senior VP of officiating may have
overturned it yes
but I think he's been more more truthful
and honest to the clear and obvious
standard and I think that's part of it
too
you have to defer to the ruling on the
field unless it's clearly and obviously
wrong we'll see what they do
the XFL already having an influence on
the NF o because that was what Vince
McMahon said hey we're not gonna try to
criticize the NFL but in the XFL we will
know what it catches he's Mike Florio
from Pro Football Talk thank you Mike
for everything this year good luck at
ESPN thank you
I probably won't be able to be on your
show just letting you know for more Dan
Patrick
to the audience channel 239 on Direct TV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]